2023 is going to be a fantastic year for
Nintendo for a lot of reasons you know
we got Zelda coming around the corner
but this isn't a review on Zelda this is
a review on Fire Emblem engage published
by Nintendo for the Nintendo switch
[Music]
what's going on you guys Lord ad here
coming at you with another review today
we're going to be reviewing Fire Emblem
engaged first off let's go over a little
history with me in Fire Emblem I don't
have a whole lot of history for the most
part three houses was the very first
review I ever did it was on my other
channel gaming attic you can definitely
go look at that if you guys want to so
when it comes to firing engage because I
enjoyed three houses so much I knew this
was going to be my type of game this is
going to be a game that really entices
me and this is the review on that game
now let's talk about the performance
first off we have said this over and
over on the IOP Channel we've set it
multiple times on this review Nintendo
we need a new Switch we need something
that's going to play these games better
at first it wasn't as bad because your
guys's game ran pretty flawlessly on the
platform but now even your games are
having a little trouble did that mean
this game ran horribly no I will say
this is one of the better performing
Nintendo switch games that I've played
in the past maybe year and a half but
well we'll say you could tell the game
was struggling it was struggling a lot
in terms of pop-ins uh loading screens
was ridiculous clearly this isn't on an
SSD of any sort I just want Nintendo to
do better when it comes to this hardware
and upgrade the hardware so we can get
better performing games at this point I
don't mind the way the majority of the
Nintendo switch games look like you know
aesthetically I feel like the graphics
for the most part always do well it's
just the performance and right now we
need a new switch so get on that
Nintendo now let's talk about the story
of Fire Emblem engaged you are a
character known as the Divine dragon
start the game out going with your
emblem it's Marth from the original Fire
Emblem keep in mind I didn't know about
this when I first started playing the
game like I said I didn't play the old
Fire Emblem so I didn't know Marth was a
main character of anything but you end
up fighting this enemy and once he's
defeated it looks like you go in some
form of sleep A Thousand Years goes by
or some huge amount of time and then you
are resurrected you are pretty much the
yin and yang of a character called the
fell dragon and what that pretty much is
is the main antagonist of the game and
that's pretty much going into it without
really spoiling much of anything I don't
want to spoil nothing for you guys now I
actually say I like this story I thought
the story was a well-toed story very
loving and engaging conversations
there's really good characters in this
game I think that Fire Emblem engage did
a very good job telling The Narrative of
this story uh you know the gameplay
definitely adds on to it there's a lot
of side missions that you can do in the
game pretty much there is just mission
after May Nation it's kind of like a
structure on a map that go from one
place to another now three houses it
wasn't like this but I was told that um
you know the older games generally went
towards something like this I don't know
if that's true or not now I see a lot of
comparisons on Twitter and stuff talking
about whether or not you know three
houses or they like engage more now as
far as just the story I would actually
say I would push more towards the three
houses storyline that doesn't mean this
story is bad I think this store is great
but I do think that there was more plot
twists going on in in in three houses
than there was going on in this game
like because that doesn't make this game
bad in any way shape or form in terms of
story but I would say that I kind of
favored the other one over this one now
let's talk about the game play you guys
know how I am gameplay is over
everything and this gameplay is
fantastic man you know first off let's
talk about the elephant in the room it's
called the emblems now pretty much what
the emblems are is characters from
previous Fire Emblem games the only
thing I wish they would have done is be
a little bit more discreet on you know
telling the story some of these
characters they did do it to a point but
I wish they would have had like their
own storyline for pretty much what
happens is every time you get a new
emblem on the map somewhere opens up
another mission that belongs to a
certain emblem that you have it could be
the new one you have or maybe that's a
previous one that you haven't done but
what I liked about this is it was a very
challenging engagements keep in mind the
challenge rate in this game is pretty
high I would honestly say if you don't
really keep up to date on the mechanics
in the game you're gonna get destroyed
you know they have a rock paper scissors
mentality on this game where you know if
you have a bow you can actually take air
support down pretty fast you know sore
brake Shield I'm pretty sure it was
sword on Shield but you guys get the
gist of it every character's got a
counter to another character and the
cool thing about this is the emblems
will actually open up more gameplay
later on down the line so for for
instance certain emblems are good with
other weapons so if you're having a
really bad time with a certain unit on
the field and your emblem actually has
his weakness it's probably best for you
to go ahead and engage get to that
weapon and then go ahead and take down
that enemy one thing I have noticed
about Fire Emblem and Gage that I don't
really remember if it was on three
houses or not it was a long time since I
played that game is the amount of
overwhelming force that the enemies have
they kind of give that you know you're
fighting your way up the bat the hill
battle the entire game where the evil
forces are by far more of a menace than
you are because they have just simply
more people and then there'll be certain
people in the game that have their own
emblems you know now I really like the
tug of war between the good side and the
bad side and how many one set has of
emblems how many of the others that have
emblems and you can really tell that you
are a fighty way uphill and there's a
point in the story where you realize
okay maybe it is possible to defeat
these people and like I said there is a
lot of combat you you could do on here
there is missions that are constantly
popping up you got the emblems side
missions you got side missions in
general you got just random battles that
you can have on the map this game does a
good job of giving you stuff to do
giving you grinding opportunities
letting you upgrade equipment letting
you change classes there's a huge class
system in here I will say that they
probably should have did a better job
explaining the class system because it
took me a couple hours to really grasp
the way that you upgrade certain people
because it's not originally filtered to
what you can do on your actual character
it's filtered to all of them and maybe
just level it up to the characters that
you can level up next to or the
characters that you can cross level up
to and I feel like that's a better
system than just showing them all
because it's a little bit more of
overwhelming sensation on man there's
all these characters and I don't really
know how to unlock any of them but it
comes it comes with the territory about
I would say a couple hours until you
definitely know where all of these are I
would say that the UI is pretty good on
that too they do have a pretty good
tutorial on here it's just the class
system to me they could have did a
little bit better on now they have a hub
world it's kind of like the monastery
from houses now pretty much what goes on
here is you're able to buy equipment to
level up your actual weapons you can go
here because the emblems will be here
and level up their bonds as well there's
actual Bond system where you can do
certain abilities there's a emblem
system where you can actually craft
other style rings with the current ones
that you currently have there's a lot of
depth into this system and I've really
hats off to the men you know these type
of games are really really fun when they
give you all of these options and they
really let you play this game how you
want to play it one thing I really want
to go over in terms of the gameplay is
the animations on this you know it's a
very beautiful game when stuff goes on
there's a lot of fighting animations
there's some really cool pictures and
really cool videos that you can make
when you know it looks like everything's
going downhill these people are about to
just completely demolish you and your
star character just Dodges five attacks
on five different enemies and just wipes
them all out it's a really nice feeling
when stuff like that happens and to be
honest with you it doesn't happen in a
lot of these type of games but I feel
like Fire Emblem really does a good job
on that with three houses now engaged
where they really do this kind of grid
space combat Justice for the most part I
would actually say that if you want to
get technical on these type of Nintendo
games Nintendo got this type of style
locked you know they got this they have
the Mario Rabbids game that just came
out if you want to play these style
games you really can't go anywhere else
but the Nintendo switch when it comes to
these style games but you know that's
pretty much the review on Fire Emblem
engaged I think the story was a pretty
good story not as good as Fire Emblem
three houses but it was still pretty
solid foundation I really enjoyed
playing what I played on it I feel like
the graphics was extremely well detailed
in this game especially animations and
fight and serve certain enemies on here
now you know obviously we could have
done better when it comes to Performance
Nintendo you need to get on that we need
a new Switch we need something to run
these games better you guys got so many
good games we need Hardware to run them
correctly and I
[Applause]
am worth the money look at 60 dollars
but I do feel like there's content here
there's enough reason to play these now
if you don't like these style games
maybe this isn't the right game for you
if you want something to play on the
Nintendo switch I would suggest picking
this up and you know try it out if you
don't like it you know you know not to
get anything like this in the future but
what I will say is they did a good job
on this I do think this is worth your
money if you like these style games if
not I definitely understand you wanting
to wait for a cell whenever Nintendo
decides to make sales on their games and
try it for a lower cost maybe you could
try three houses you know it's not
exactly the same thing but it's the same
concept to a lot of degree and if you
like that game then commit to this game
that's probably what I would suggest if
you don't play these games try three
houses first you could probably get that
a lot cheaper and then try this game
after that game because I feel like if
you like three houses or if you like you
know XCOM to a point that type of
gameplay it's not exactly the same thing
but it's a grid style man I think you'll
enjoy this game anyway that's the review
for you guys guys I really enjoyed this
it didn't run the greatest on the
Nintendo switch but I enjoyed every
second of it put in the comment section
below are you guys fans of Fire Emblem
I'm very curious to hear you guys
opinion down there and don't forget to
like this video if you found it
informative if you enjoyed it you can
always subscribe to the channel we do
weekly podcasts every Sunday at 1pm you
can catch the Lords talking about gaming
in general and until next time this is
Lord addict and I'm out of here peace
[Music]
thank you